[Applause]
all right do you remember 1969
i do some call it the good old days i
don't it sucked
dow jones was at 800 the average income
per year was under 9 grand
something called woodstock took place
look at these people you know they just
smelled bad
like a fish's jock strap
i don't know if they wore them but they
could but also stunk fashion
people actually wore this stuff outside
and they weren't pelted with hot garbage
basically the world reaped but i
couldn't do a thing i was just five
years old
here's a picture
i
i was adorable i was adorable but i
could do nothing
to make the world a better place so
instead i
ate as much plato as possible the point
is
1969 was a long time ago 49 years ago
and you'd have to go back that far to
find jobless numbers
that are this good today it's true
applications for unemployment benefits
are now at a 49-year low
that's almost five decades long or what
i call
one episode of the view so
all right easy joke so
trump trump's job numbers are so good
to match it you'd have to go back to an
era when not
bathing was considered an achievement
that's what we call good news and humans
like good news
but not all humans he just tweeted their
uh
meeting in singapore on june 12th
and we'll both try to make a very
special moment
for world peace well you know good for
him
if it works we're happy for him
[Laughter]
you could just feel joy's pain
when she said that it's it's like she
realized
that wasn't a fart
but there are a lot of humans that don't
like good news
they're called wet blankets their
release
should not be exalted it should be
expected
it is no great accomplishment of kim
jong-un to do this
and when the president does it
he weakens american foreign policy
and puts americans at risk around the
world
talk about the opposite of fun to him
the glass is half empty
much like his skull so
here we have great news but many
politicians and media hacks all they see
is bad
if only there were a drug to help them
unemployment has hit 3.9 percent that's
good news for the american worker
coalition forces are said to deliver a
fatal blow
to isis oh this is not good
you should talk to your doctor you may
be suffering from wbs
what's that
wbs stands for wet blanket syndrome
anything good happens
you see it as bad news news anchors get
it all the time
three americans held hostage in north
korea are on their way home right now
am i going to die doc there's no cure
for wbs
thanks to holodecks you can live with it
holodex tricks your brain into thinking
every day is the day before a three-day
weekend making it virtually impossible
for you to be nothing but happy
all the time unemployment is at its
lowest in 17 years and president trump
deserves the credit
and we're clear ah that week went fast
time for three days of fun in the sun
here comes the beach
dude it's only wednesday almost had me
kevin
you're a laugh riot thanks holidex
dude what the [ __ ] is that guy on so get
holodecks today
your co-workers won't get it but we do
every every day
is the day before a three-day weekend
that is some really surreal okay
back to the real good news it wasn't
just a human victory
but a ratings one too it's very early in
the morning
i think you probably broke the all-time
in history television rating for three
o'clock in the morning
that i would say of course don't you
love that he did this at 3am could have
been any other time
but he chose then why to tell you that
he's always
up he's always up for
us at every hour
and if you had hillary instead she'd
already be out like a broken headlight
speaking
speaking of thinking of hillary if if
she were
president and had a week like trumps how
might the press react
[Applause]
[Music]
but instead with trump you get this
[Music]
which is why he had to blow his own horn
on thursday
we are rocking we are rock
kim jong-un kim
jong-un sleep and joe we have great
health care plans coming out they
weren't saying
merry christmas now they're saying
merry christmas again america
is respected again i have delivered more
than i promised i go
back
oh my god so is he gloating who cares he
should gloat the rallies are where you
get the good news
that the media often ignores it's trump
news
and he's the anchor of course what were
the other news buckets full of
so the lawyer for stormy daniels is
stepping up his attacks i almost forgot
about what i was going to talk about but
of course
michael cohen it doesn't seem like he
was very good at it i mean the the money
to stormy daniels the porn star didn't
work didn't silence her
certainly is not illegal from what we
know but it looks
bad it has the stench of the swamp and
that stench affects both trump and cohen
man these networks are so obsessed with
porn they should be sponsored by kleenex
now now imagine
america as the world's greatest
all-inclusive resort
with water slides and pool bars and
casinos
and where's the media they're hiding in
the hotel room watching tv
and it's stuck on the view it's weird
it's like the media can't see themselves
or even the outside world it's as if
they're
trapped living in some gigantic
footprint
left by king kong except it's not kong's
footprint at
all it's trump's
after he stomped on them in 2016
and so they've all fallen in and they
can't get up
i fear that if someone doesn't throw
them a rope ladder they're going to end
up eating each other alive
which sucks i hate cannibals they're so
full of
all
themselves
let's welcome tonight's guest she's so
bright
fireflies try to catch her and put her
in the jar
author and tv host jenna diablo
he's tackled more roles than michael
moore's masseuse
thank you actor daniel roebuck
she's brassy sassy and her gaze a little
glassy national review reporter cat
he keeps his pants up with an asteroid
belt
former wwe superstar massive sidekick
tyrus
all right this was just my turn
jedidiah yes all this chaos going around
and he's still getting stuff done how is
this possible
yeah because he's actually i mean this
is what people elected him to do right i
mean he was saying some crazy stuff and
everyone acknowledged she had this crazy
past but we were like
we want a guy i didn't vote for him i
voted for rand paul but still most
people were like we want a guy that's
going to get the job done and that's
what he's doing and
it's hysterical when you watch these
videos because i think the media is so
invested in his demise they have decided
that
you know they went on record and said
this guy's going to be a big failure
he's going to be a big joke he's a
reality tv star
yeah so when he does well they look dumb
they look like well they weren't paying
attention their predictions are wrong so
they're invested in him failing and they
don't care
that that may mean that the american
people actually suffer
that your paychecks will be lower that
our national security might be
threatened so it's fascinating to watch
because
you know specifically with the the
prisoners that were brought back that
was a story that everyone across the
aisle
you know both sides of the aisle had to
come forward and acknowledge this was a
good thing he did
but you watch them and they're suffering
they're suffering to say
it and it's so transparent that it's
it's it lets everybody know that
everyone who's been saying the media is
biased
they tell you they show you right in
their own face it's hard for them i feel
bad do you want to see my impression of
voting for
rand paul
[Applause]
listen i still voted yeah i still voted
and i give him credit where credit's due
this guy's doing a lot of really good
things this was a great week for him
and i mean i'm really proud to have him
as my president this week and i'll say
that anytime he does something good
all right roebuck what are your thoughts
on this week and overall
anything i thought this was a fantastic
week to celebrate
being an american uh there's a lot of
there's a lot of people who
who talk about how horrible it is to be
an american and i always think
uh really yeah like like we're not the
ones holding anyone prisoner
yeah like no one's being held against i
mean criminals are being held we hold
them prisoner
and we're all for that i think yeah you
know disagreeing with the government we
generally let you walk around and yeah
we give you tv shows and we make you
famous so
this is a great week for everyone who
who doesn't disagree
with the government who does agree with
the government i'm happy to be an
american
just like jenna died
cat cat in the green room you said if
you could vote for trump 18
times you would i voted for gary johnson
i know you didn't throw the something on
when she said that
unbreakable if i if i throw something
here it's all gonna break that's
she's a permanent guest on the show so
she gets treated with respect i see
sometimes no but again
credit where credit's due and it
shouldn't be hard to be happy that
prisoners are back in the united states
from north korea it shouldn't be
difficult to be excited about that
and obviously president trump deserves
credit i know because i couldn't do it
yeah i tried yeah you did you didn't try
to free prisoners i tried but you never
replied to my emails
yes please
i used like the really cute emojis and
for some reason they stayed there and
you get president trump in there and you
got to give him credit for doing it and
you know but people
focused all week on saying the world's
going to end because we're not in the
audit
or we're not in the iran deal anymore
we're out of it and i've noticed that
they said the world was going to end
when he called kim jong-un little rocket
man
yeah he said the world was going to end
when he got elected in the first place
and i like keep waking up in the morning
yes
and everything's fine yes so i kind of
feel like maybe it's not
yeah no i think you're right i do that
sense of pattern he creates chaos and
from chaos comes solutions i do predict
though tomorrow you will get a lot of
letters from inmates
even more even more than usual even more
than usual
do you think um donald trump's past of
dealing with like unseemly people and
real estate
stuff and and mob and everything helped
him
yeah because it wasn't he dealing with a
criminal tyrant
yes in kim jong-un yes yeah it takes
sometimes it takes a wolf
you know because shepherds don't get it
done but
i think it's it's the north korea thing
is such a big thing
and it's so hard for the other side and
they're looking for anything did you
when they they finally uh when they
talked about the where the place was
going to be at where the meeting was
going to be at
right they're like singapore and they're
like
i think don lemon said singapore loosely
translated as asian russia
like they literally were trying anything
you know that's isn't is that some of
the kremlin's favorite vacation spot
like they're trying anything
to link to there's a link just to ruin
something like yeah
singapore horrible hotels there can't
believe you picked that place yes
you know they just really are they can't
they just can't give it to him
but i understand why because we all
donald trump is that guy
that we all went to school with that
like had the nice car
had the prettiest girlfriend and then
whenever he gets a straight a or
whatever and he tells hey i aced that
yeah you know what man i hate this dude
he's always
and i feel like i feel like that's where
cnn is right now every time he does
something they're like
just
just the coverage though like stormy
daniels i mean this stuff's on 24
7. the job stuff you can't even find it
you gotta
search for that this is trump's rally
this is one exact
case where i'm actually tired of seeing
a porn star
really all right coming i know hard to
believe